hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to animal inspector I found
this game on it Gio because it looked
adorable but it seemed to have rather
sinister implications such as this
newspaper article to many animals
government declares animal crisis can I
read the comics oh [ __ ]
gun fancy the last buck meets its hunter
oh geez hunting in a world with how wild
animals oh jeez
Oh secret murder agency please don't
kill me oh god the president wants your
pets they came for my cat Oh snout and
soul
first impressions oh wow the cat that
dodged inspection okay oh hi oh holy
[ __ ] how are you hi pup hello dog oh my
perfect boy how are you doing what do I
put on I suppose my truest friend I
agree dago's are the best
noble and fierce yeah you'll be
inspected soon ok it doesn't sound good
but I won't wait for that they're hiring
agents I've already applied you're a
good dog I won't let them take you good
ok great I'm gonna save the animals I'm
gonna save all the dog O's yeah I'm an
inspector Oh three one five bring it on
oh hello there my name is Martha it is
wonderful to meet you dear are you just
starting out here as well yeah
dragged a fish toy into my mouth oh my
god
the Tex thing is a giant cat Oh God
oh how exciting well I am very much
looking forward to this it will be good
for me to get out of the house I just do
not get out as much as I should do you
see that young man over there no well
now I do
hello
I tried talking to him earlier his name
is Alan he was a little rude so I'm glad
that you're here
oh but enough of this I'm very excited
to work with you well to work near you
in any case okay oh boy hey you all are
the new employees okay
well I'm in charge here um listen up
this job is pretty straightforward every
day you'll get a stack of forms go
through each one and stamp them approve
good or useful animals reject bad or
useless animals don't skip any oh god
it's like a papers please
stifle animal inspection we take this
job very seriously um oh yeah one more
thing please make sure to comment on
every animal you process explain your
reasoning oh jeez it's a legal thing
yeah I don't know that's it I guess okay
cool Oh God little like feeding the chat
box okay that's it
isn't there any training a rule book or
something um no use your best judgment
I'll let you know if you screwed up oh
but try not to screw up okay [ __ ] the
stack of forms on your desk I'm starting
it all off easy but please be thorough
well I don't know he seems nice
you think so too right no hmm oh dear
well it seems that our day is about to
begin
it's time to go inspect some animals
yeah do try to be a little more
enthusiastic dear these animals need you
after all
oh look a goodie always a goof
oh I said a goof we all love this fuzzy
dog a lot Oh adorable dog Oh a plus-plus
wood dog Oh again check box yeah did I
screw up this mean next okay let's see
nature aloof kills mice she didn't let
me touch her until a few months ago but
now I pet her every day all right
good hunter hunter Katims quick yeah I'm
doing great house cat timid reminder of
simpler days he easily becomes afraid
but this cat is good he is family family
means Ohana Hana is fam fam boy oh [ __ ]
there we go
yeah I got a thumbs up am I good alright
please tell me I'm good okay um welcome
back I guess pretty good job yesterday
pretty good some of you and I won't name
any names but you know who you are have
been a little too liberal with rules the
whole point of this agency is to call to
herd that means you can't just watch Lee
huh driving through now I don't need you
to reject at least one animal feel you
deduce it will roll to the string oh
well um I didn't really think I need to
do explain this but well when you
comment on forums you should um you try
to spell things correctly yeah yeah no
mistakes happen but your job is kind of
not to make mistakes and you made some
with that last batch maybe you don't
think spelling is important but you're
professional now so please try to act
like it it's a warning the same but if
it happens again I'll have to give you a
strike oh damn it okay so there's just a
warning but please clean up your forms a
little bit before turning them in there
should be a little feather duster on
your desk standard-issue
so use it maybe no okay um seriously Wow
I'm just gonna pretend like I didn't
hear that anyway Oh God come on hello
again how's your first day bad I'm sorry
to hear that dear my day was grand
that's wonderful and cute animals I had
of course I approved them all though I
guess I cannot do that anymore good luck
today dear
hey you never really talked earlier I'm
Alan I don't think I'll be here very
long is bottom-of-the-barrel stuff
sincerely bad like really just the worst
you know what I'm saying yeah yep
actually I do Alan
good yeah you get me anyway it's good to
meet ya hi Alan
oh it's ass Nick oh this is my snake
it's very neat but my friends are scared
of it but I'm not oh come on clean it up
clean it clean okay did it alright see
housecat nervous sheds civilian appeal
none well
the dopiest cat might be going soon
ancient hound resigned good for petting
mics the family dog he's old but part of
the household Oh Oh someone out there
watching is gonna hate me for what I Pig
oh it's an old dog oh but I can't it
looks just like Lucy Oh cricket
wonderful dog Lucy Oh God oh this is
quiet snake ah snakes eat mice no need
for elimination no need for calling I
guess is a good word
Oh God I'm sorry sorry I'm so sorry
good that's all I'm gonna say did I do
good
did I do good oh don't give me a strike
well uh it's a new day so um there's a
bit of space concern basically what I
mean by that is there are some concerns
about space specifically the space all
these animals are take it up I guess
what I'm trying to say is please
prioritize projection of larger animals
all things being equal anyways anything
close to human size system talking about
a lot of people sized animals
unbelievable after all the whole point
of this is to well to make space I guess
what's its QP hmm hello dear sorry but
I'm a little down today heard that Allen
has been rejecting all of his animals I
just do not agree with that but he does
not want to listen to me called me I'll
do you said that I'm out of touch can
you believe that
No No thank you dear we were so much
nicer than Allen also I'm not proud of
it but I rejected an animal not a cat of
course
whew it was a fish the natural enemy of
cats oh yeah okay but still did not feel
good not at all dear I know we have our
instructions but I do not think you
should be rejecting cats I just do not
think it is right
cats are very intelligent creatures you
know in some ways again it smarter than
you me okay I was on your side for a
little bit there you need to back off
with you it's maybe a lot of ways
smarter okay well then Martha why don't
you take your [ __ ] nish and take it
and go have fun with your cats that I
reject so do you understand now you
promise to approve the cat's no oh I
guess that was a hard promise to make
but I think maybe you could have tried
well I guess I'll see you later okay boy
how's it going I've been getting rid of
pretty much all my animals
seriously I've got no tolerance for
useless things I mean I love this job
but I'm gonna do it well see you around
alright [ __ ] you Alan oh look at him oh
look at him Oh Oh ant oh we can get rid
of ants but they're tiny oh jeez Oh
feisty little pump oh no no the dogs big
Oh No [ __ ] the ants get out of your
hands
ants have no use well they have some use
but I'm just gonna say that whew feisty
feisty dog is good dog
approve quick let's see big because he
has lots of love to give
I wish I could misspell there's David
I'm doing link and boink okay so good
morning I just got word from the
department head basically well they
think you've all been doing great really
great so great in fact that they're
bumping up the inspection quota so uh
when I have five animals each to look
through all so this means you need to
reject two because there are more wool
though by the way I'm starting to
question your judgment that dog did an
inspection agent we didn't terminate it
right there was just a formality
I shouldn't have to double-check your
work now honestly that's kind of my
entire job I can tell that you're gonna
be a problem employee
strike for you on this but come on look
a little smarter look here this job is
not what I thought it would be
I'm trying my best to be fair to these
animals but it's not very easy the boss
is giving us lots of instructions
instructions I do not always agree with
oh man this job I don't want to say this
too loudly but well it's boring yeah a
real drag repetitive God can you imagine
doing this for the rest of your life you
feel appreciation of education oh man
poor Martha he's basically at the end of
her life ugh geez ancients oh just look
at her oh heck Muppets I'm looking at
you okay nice
and yet this where everything lender man
you're really happy it's not me like I
said I don't think I'll be here long oh
alright I guess you might be here a
while too well hey I mean this is what
makes you happy than cool well it's not
oh look at the kid
Oh little squeaky beaky oh yeah that is
shouting ah
just give it Matt give it the sound of a
rooster
oh let's kill this one the sound of a
rooster - parama both at the same time
oh jeez I gotta pick between cats birth
is not gonna like this one oh oh they're
so cute oh no they're twins I can't get
rid of the twins I mean I can't get rid
of one twin I'd have to get rid of both
twins Oh God we're gonna pick Morgan a
pig oh god the twins
I'll let the twins go together Oh God
twins need to be together - oh no Oh
sage is a good name affectionate is good
oh boy
finding stuff is cool uh-huh I'm
emotionally devastated at the most
pretty good look good um okay so I'm
sorry to say it but all Mindy has come
down with the case of the flu ooh you
know Mindy Oh Mindy Martha everyone
knows Mindy
in any case um well someone needs to
take her place in the cages today that
someone is Alan okay yeah okay well cool
I'm up for anything
Alan's been chosen because of his
exemplary exemplary execs limb flurry um
exemplary there you go performance here
these past few weeks
right on you all have been doing well so
no need to worry about increased quotas
good work out there everybody oh oh dear
what do you think about that crazy well
I'm sure glad that I'm not going the
cages are no place for me dear I've
heard some bad things about that place
very scary things things are not good at
all dear by the way dear I just wanted
to tell you that I understand I
understand that you had to reject those
cats I'm not sure that I would have been
able to do the same I still do not agree
but I know this job is important to you
I'm glad that it was not Alan who
inspected the cats I just hope that I do
not have to make that choice yeah oh man
I'm not exactly sure what to expect but
and it seems better than doing paperwork
all day
honestly I'm pumped about it very
excited thrilled this is the beginning
of a good thing for me I can feel it
okay oh oh look at the cat oh it kills
birds it's basically doing my job for us
dog useless dog just takes up space Oh
see oh wait a minute whoa hang on a
second wait what wait what man arrogant
26 I'm 26
this is me it's that Alan not Alan bad
face I don't know I don't know what that
means
62 years old all right
gold golden fish is dead fish dead it's
okay let's see
I appreciate a good squawk all dogs are
useful ok let's see what happens when I
reject the person I wonder if this is
actually gonna do something for me
wait a minute oh ok well I think I speak
for all of us when I say documentaries
are great documentaries are important
government tools they show the public
that we're just like that my favorite
documentary is uh well I forget the
title but it's about a wolf raised by
geese the wolf grows up and eats the
geese it's a message we all can learn
from them in any case there's a reason
I'm bringing this up believe it or not
they're making a documentary about this
department so in order to present us all
in the best possible light I'm asking
you well telling you actually I'm
telling you to approve all your animals
today
understood No
ok well if you want to get fired that
badly then there's not much I can do to
stop you um oh and an unannounced
announcement before you start seems a
talent is no longer Oh everything's fine
but whoa well there was an issue with
the cages whoa just a slight mix-up oh
it's uh nothing too much to worry about
that was Alan Oh I rejected Alan he was
a good employee a good boy he'll be
missed
oh no oh oh dear what could have
happened Alan I did not like him much
but just very concerning here I told you
I had heard bad things about that place
if the boss does not come a little worn
down tear this documentary will be very
exciting the thing
it means we do not have to reject any
animals I'll tell you though I'm getting
a little worried about my cats have not
come up for inspection yet very anxious
I just want them to be okay
oh look at the dog oh hey cat how you
doing fish dude I care everything here
is a feeder I'll just go ahead and
reject the oh no I need to approve
everything okay oh okay all righty then
Oh dog Oh Oh dog owes Oh adorable dog
owes everything it's love love it great
bird
it's the awesome dog swell up good smile
all right clean him up send him up
well d-day has come and gone
that's doc day by the way documentary
day because they were filming a
documentary at Yeti yes a good news mad
news the good news is that the filming
went well they got all the shots he
needed they're done with his office the
bad news is that we're now extremely
behind under rejection quota so um I'm
gonna need you to all reject everything
today no exemptions no no I thought
things were getting better around here
yesterday was so nice but the day will
be awful I'm not sure if I can do it
maybe all of our animals will be bad
today that's possible right dear
No oh oh oh oh no oh no I know it's
gonna happen her cats are gonna come up
oh no invites kindness
the cat is my baby I did love her so
much I have to I have to save it I have
to save it oh my god I'm killing the dog
house in favor do it I can't do it so
sorry I'm so sorry she barked in a rock
oh you're lucky my mother had a saying
hang in there I don't think she made it
up but she sure said it a lot um I guess
what I'm trying to say is I know things
are rough but remember to hang in there
uh that being said Mindy is sick again
little Mindy it's really been sick a lot
recently
suspicious Wow and take over last time
enough pull he's not with us anymore so
it's your turn you'll take over for
Mindy today to set down to the cages
I'll follow you down to the pier with
instructions okay you what didn't you
understand you're really so hard to just
reject everything there's nothing to
think about
Oh God oh I'm sorry let's step back a
bit I guess I do understand
Martha's cat well um it's cold cuz it's
good to stick together I really do have
to address this so you missed our quota
yesterday the records are clear and
someone has to take the fall I still
need to give a strike this is only for
your first strike so don't worry too
much but if you get three you're done
also okay well we should talk I know I
never mentioned this before but I'm well
you I really need to bury your comments
like don't just write the same thing oh
come on randomly every creature is
special and they all deserve to die I
get it I guess um well anyways just
treat each gate separately oh my
goodness dear my cat my lovely kidding
you saved her dear you will never know
how much this means to me
you must have gotten a strike for this
I'm so sorry about that I do not think
you liked me I'm so happy to be wrong
again thank you so much on please be
careful dear I still think about what
happened to Alan the boss will not talk
about it with me something bad is going
on I can feel it
Oh No welcome to the cages oh it looks
so much different down here you're
probably wondering where all the actual
cages are well rest assured there are
definitely some cages in here there
behind a few more doors you'll see them
soon but first I'm sure you have a few
questions maybe that you wanted to ask
what this place is yeah let's go with
that I thought though I'll tell you
you've been part of a little experiment
well I guess it's more of a big
experiment but anyways I have a few
questions for you
then I'll explain everything please try
to answer as honestly as possible
Wow what first question have you noticed
anything odd during your time here yes
hmm interesting
oh you don't want me to expand on that
oh okay
this goal of this organization clear for
you no okay let me just mark that down
third question would you describe
everyone here is normal no ah would you
describe Martha as abnormal no huh what
about me
weird rude well [ __ ] you too all right
I did ask though hmm well I think we're
just about done here thanks very much
for your time so I guess you noticed
there's something funny going on
well I'll explain a few things so first
of all Alan rest in peace Alan wasn't a
real person what what I mean by that is
that Alan wasn't always the way he was
the Alan you were interacting with was
actually an animal what a dog
specifically neat right
hey kinda that's right hell yeah it is
anyways look we've been researching how
to train animals to do annum menial
labor like your job stamping forms we
can train animals to do it of course to
do that we have to set them up with
nicer brains and we see those brains
with human memories so they can actually
function in Alan's case we gave him
Alan's memories Alan the dog's case we
gave the dog Alan the memories of human
Alan a knot that the dog Allen's name
was originally Alan to I mean that would
be weird coincidence anyways when you
have someone's memories you kind of
freak out if you don't actually look
like them
so then we make that happen look I won't
get into the specifics like technology
is pretty advanced these days so we can
basically make an animal pass as human
and we don't have to pay them so all
these pets we've been rejecting they're
an untapped workforce and we're tapping
them of course you didn't notice that
something was off so we still have some
work to do human sized animals they
wanted rejected oh but yeah that makes
sense no okay well I mean look I don't
mean to imply this ideas bulletproof we
have to admit it's pretty solid dot dot
dot okay hold up what's your problem
name one issue with this plan just one
cost
huh I guess it is a little absurd how
much money we've put into this we
probably won't ever really make it back
the money isn't everything some of
mankind's greatest achievements were
profitable so that's all you gotta claim
about morals well yes we were
experimenting with people's pets we kind
of wiped out the wilderness a little
that's not great and I mean if we're
giving an animal so much memories it's
really so different than us at that
point and what would happen if someone
met their animal cloned it's kind of
spooky to be honest but that's a price
we pay for progress the greater good
you'll all be worth it in the end
really of course I mean probably maybe
well I guess there's not any obvious
benefit but we're in too deep at this
point we just got to keep pushing
through you have to agree with that
right no not really
look I know there are some issues here
like it's kind of weird that we're using
animals for this robots would probably
have been made more sense
kinda strategies of Technology and I
mean what's the end goal here
what's all the jobs are done by animals
then what plus if the animals think
they're human then oh we probably will
have to pay them okay so this whole plan
is a little weird just a tiny bit but I
think we've covered all the flaws at
this point I mean ever plan as its
downside all right any absolutes in this
world this plan may not be perfect but
really what is so you see now right
you're on board with our strategy no
listen
I'm getting real sick of your attitude
here I was trying to be nice about this
tried to answer all your questions but I
can see that you aren't gonna be
cooperative I don't think I'd really let
you leave at this point you're a
troublemaker a real piece of work
so is your home now well you'll be
pleased to know that your replacement
will be your very own dog
so it's not all bad anyway um welcome to
the rest of your life oh wow oh god no
oh jeez wow what a game what an
adventure
oh geez oh it's all my approvals it's
all my cards family means aha no huh its
fanfare Oh dorable Dargo good hand here
Katims Oh No oh geez oh geez it's all my
sins it's all my sins lay bare oh man
that was awesome that was awesome I
really like that I like that a lot
that was an awesome game I can't
describe it any more than awesome and
try not to use the c-word you know the
word I'm talking about not that C word
but the other C word but you know this
is a great game I liked it a lot so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to play this I'll put a link
to it in the description below
apparently there's probably a lot of
different ways to go about this game and
maybe a different ending to explore
maybe multiple different endings I have
no idea but anyway you'll find that out
for yourself let me know what you
thought of this in the comments blood I
really want to hear your opinions on it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video